okay let's get into our first audience
questions for 2021 of very good ones
ones I'm looking forward to answering
first is David do you think we really
could be approaching a secession Civil
War scenario after January 20th I think
that the answer is no now if you step
back and say well I'm going to just
focus on are there secessionist
movements and is there a group that
would love to use militia organization
and militia power to separate or to go
against what is going to be a Biden run
federal government yeah there's no
shortage of that but the country has
changed dramatically from the times of
the Civil War in the Civil War you had
two very clearly defined factions they
were geographically much more
homogeneous than what we have now where
you have even in red States the cities
are often blue
even in blue States the rural areas are
often red right and now it's a very
Urban rural situation within states in
the Civil War it was different each side
had a a military to back it up in a more
sort of um equal way and so right now a
lot of different things have changed
first there's this sort of geographical
complexity uh it's not clear like which
states would be part of which side Urban
rural within States is the sort of
circumstance number two Financial
red states are not viable without blue
States and we've talked a lot about when
you look at whether States pay in more
or get more back from the federal
government the blue States
overwhelmingly pay in more whereas the
red states are more likely to be leeches
and receive more from the federal
government and absent that a lot of
those red States would not even be
financially viable and my my guess would
be is if you see some of these uh groups
militias Etc escalate into bombings
shootings Etc you would see the tide
turn with police and National Guard
forces likely putting them down without
even getting to some kind of a more
Federal response however I mean like
let's think ahead if you imagine these
red States somehow come together and
they say we're going to use our or
combine our State National Guard cards
I'm speaking so hypothetically
um the the reddest States all together
have National Guard forces of about 200
000 troops
and the federal government is about a
million and a half troops and they have
all the real Firepower and so from a
purely logistical perspective I'm not
saying that right-wing militias can't
cause chaos oh they absolutely can they
can cause chaos they can cause death
they can do horrible horrible things but
the circumstances are simply not uh ones
that would lend themselves to a true
Civil War and if the federal uh Army if
the Army were to be used by the federal
level
um uh to suppress this you know
homegrown militias are not going to be a
match for the U.S military For Better or
Worse we can talk about military
industrial complex we can talk about all
of these other things
um but I actually think the more
interesting topic is
are there enough just people willing and
interested in that I know that you know
you half the country or a third for 35
percent of the country didn't vote of
the people that voted for Trump
um half believe that Trump is ultimately
going to be sworn in some of those when
Trump is not sworn in might be really
really angry and some subset of those
might want to secede and some subset of
those might be willing to actually go
and fight for that in some way the point
is I don't think there's enough people
actually interested in that that you're
really going to see any significant
movement along those lines and I've
talked before we have an economic
situation that is designed to prevent
people from organizing in that way and
if this is for better or worse I've
talked about how cheap stuff from China
combined with easy access to credit
um credit cards and personal credit
keeps people relatively comfortable
enough doesn't mean that there's no
poverty doesn't mean that there's no
hunger but even people who otherwise
might not like without credit and cheap
stuff from China there would be lots of
people who on a day-to-day uh um live
far worse far less comfortably than they
do so a lot of people are just gonna say
do it you know I kind of would rather
just hang out and you know watch sports
not do whatever it is this these
secessionists want me to do
combined with the fact that due to
stagnant wages and the precarious
financial situation of many people a lot
of people you know oh let's go let's go
uh wage a Civil War and try to secede
I'll be gone for two weeks wait a second
then I lose health care and lose my
income and then if we don't succeed when
I get back what do I have I lose my
house my car gets repossessed or
whatever so that is to some degree by
Design in the system that we have and
I've spoken about that before so I do
not expect that that is going to lead to
anything even approximating the real
threat of what we might recognize as a
civil war
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a practical and
affordable way to take control of your
health and get personalized care from
the comfort of your home it's a service
called steady MD they're one of our
sponsors you take a quiz you get matched
with a licensed primary care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor you establish a meaningful
relationship with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call each doctor at
steady MD has a limited number of
patients so they actually have time to
listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve they can do
almost everything an in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns send
prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy and anything they can't do
online they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example you don't need
insurance it's only 99 bucks a month
with no other fees or co-pays I took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular Health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs they have a special offer
only for my audience you'll get 50 off
your first month but only until January
31st so make sure to sign up soon click
the link right underneath this video